est ce que vous connaissez facile le
match qu est un boxeur ukrainien encore
en activité et c'est le boxeur le plus
technique qui ait jamais existé
il est si rapide et si précis que ses
adversaires qui sont pourtant le
meilleur boxeur au monde ses adversaires
abandonne de découragement et voici
comment le match nko'o explique son
succès un boxeur gagne un boxeur père
c'est simplement que l'un est mieux
préparé l'autre moins bien préparés donc
s'il lomachenko cartonne sur le ring
c'est parce qu'il se prépare très
sérieusement et très spécifiquement il
ne fait pas les choses au hasard il suit
une stratégie vous voulez cartonné en
dissertation mon concours vous avez
besoin de la bonne stratégie
ça fait une dizaine d'années que je
prépare des candidats aux épreuves de
dissertation des concours ali plus
difficile hec polytechnique les concours
administratifs
les concours de la fonction publique etc
je remarque toujours la même chose
vous ne savez pas où vous allez pour la
plupart vous vous dites que vous allez
réviser le court faire les ds prévu au
cours de l'année et puis vous espérez
que ça va marcher mais non ça ne va pas
marcher
si vous faites la même chose que tous
les candidats vous aurez les mêmes
résultats que tous les candidats
donc si vous voulez car tenez vous avez
besoin d'une stratégie pour cartonner et
bien et je vais vous révéler les trois
clés de cette stratégie dans cette vidéo
une petite précision avant de commencer
je ne vais pas vous dire les choses
évidentes que vous connaissez déjà parce
que je ne veux pas vous faire perdre
votre temps je sais que vous avez
beaucoup de travail par exemple
vous devez bien sûr et bien connaître
les modalités de votre époque de
dissertation le programme de la matière
etc
ça ne servira à rien que je vous en
parle non je vais vous donner des
techniques de préparation auquel vous
n'avez pas pensé
regardez donc attentivement cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout et vous ferez partie de la
minorité des candidats de votre concours
qui savent comment se préparer pour
cartonner en dissertation de même qu'un
excès de nourriture gâte l'estomac et
nuit à l'organisme tout entier on peut
aussi par un excès de nourriture
intellectuelle surchargé et étouffer
l'esprit schopenhauer
la première clé pour cartonner en
dissertation à votre concours c'est de
préparer un stock de connaissances
pourquoi est ce que c'est si important
et bien parce que votre problème c'est
l'excès d'information il y a trop de
choses que vous devez savoir à quoi bon
avoir un cours de plusieurs centaines de
pages
ça prend un temps fou à réviser vous ne
retiendrez jamais tout et vous ne
maîtriserez pas ce que vous retiendrez
c'est à dire que vous aurez du mal à
mobiliser vos connaissances en
dissertation c'est comme lorsque vous
faites les courses vous n'achetez pas 10
kg de bananes d'un coup parce que vous
n'avez pas besoin d'autant de bananes et
si vous pensez finir les 10 kg au bout
de plusieurs mois vous ne pourrez pas
parce que les bananes vont pourrir en
pratique vous savez donc à peu près de
quelle quantité de bananes vous avez
besoin pour la semaine à venir
et bien pour la dissertation c'est
pareil vous n'avez pas besoin de
centaines de pages de cours vous devez
donc estimer la quantité de savoirs
nécessaires pour être en mesure de
réussir vos épreuves de dissertation et
ça ce n'est pas très difficile
vous devez simplement vous poser les
bonnes questions de combien de
connaissances ou de référence
avez vous besoin dans une dissertation
par exemple dans une dissertation de
trois fois trois parties on a besoin de
dix références une pour la croche et une
pour chaque paragraphe du développement
audrey question que vous devez vous
poser votre stock de connaissances c'est
un faire combien de pages à peu près
s'il est trop grosse à prendre a trop de
temps à réaliser
et s'il est trop court vous serez
peut-être à sec pour traiter certains
sujets alors ça dépend bien sûr de la
taille de la police et d'autres facteurs
de mise en forme mais au doigt mouillé
je pense que vous ne devriez pas
dépasser 100 pages
autre exemple de question que vous devez
vous poser quelle est l'ampleur de votre
programme
quelle quantité de connaissances est ce
que vous devez sélectionner par thème
pour être à l'aise lors de votre épreuve
par exemple si vous préparez une
dissertation d'économies combien de
théories de statistiques et d'exemples
historiques
est-ce que vous avez intérêt à retenir
pour chaque chapitre de votre programme
vous ne pouvez pas tout retenir soyez
donc très pragmatique regarder
précisément votre programme identifier
les types de connaissances dont vous
avez besoin penser autant que vous allez
devoir investir pour créer votre stock
de connaissances mais aussi ensuite pour
l'apprendre et soyez réaliste nous
surestimons toujours nos besoins et il
n'y a que 24 heures dans une journée
je ne peux pas vous donner des
indications plus précises parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de concours différents et des
preuves de dissertation différentes
donc si vous voulez des indications que
précise posez moi vos questions dans les
commentaires et je vous répondrai avec
plaisir maintenant une fois que vous
avez estimé la quantité de savoirs
nécessaires pour réussir votre épreuve
vous devez le formater en vue de
l'exercice de la dissertation vous devez
rendre vos connaissances facile à
utiliser en dissertation et pour ça vous
devez faire trois choses tout d'abord
clarifier les connaissances parce que si
vous ne les comprenais pas vous ne
pourrez pas les mobiliser efficacement
en dissertation et puis c'est cette
première nécessité la clarification qui
rend possible la deuxième la deuxième
chose que vous devez faire pour formater
les connaissances en vue de la
dissertation c'est de les relier à des
idées essentielles des thèmes du
programme
pourquoi est ce que vous devez faire ça
pour commencé d'ores et déjà à réfléchir
dans la perspective de l'argumentation
pour le dire plus simplement à chaque
fois que vous voyez une connaissance que
vous pourriez ajouter à votre stock vous
vous dites ça pourrait me servir à
montrer ça ou bien à montrer ça c'est à
dire que vous essayez d'anticiper les
arguments auxquels vous pouvez apporter
du crédit grâce à la connaissance en
question en fait vous vous demandez si
la connaissance sera rentable et ça
c'est important parce que vous ne créez
pas un stock de connaissances pour vous
faire plaisir ou pour améliorer votre
culture générale
mais pour réussir vos épreuves de
dissertation le savoir que vous préparez
doit être utile je vais vous donner
quelques exemples
si vous mettez dans votre stock la
théorie des lisiers de platon vous
pouvez anticiper que cette théorie vous
servira à apporter du crédit à l'idée
selon laquelle la vérité n'est pas dans
l'apparence ou bien à l'idée selon
laquelle le philosophe doit pas revenir
à la vraie connaissance vous donner un
autre exemple si en économie vous notez
dans votre stock de connaissances la
théorie du multiplicateur de kind vous
pouvez anticiper que cette théorie vous
servir à apporter du crédit à l'idée
selon laquelle l'état peut intervenir
efficacement dans l'économie ou bien à
l'idée selon laquelle l'état peut
soutenir la demande sans alourdir la
fiscalité
allez un dernier petit exemple si vous
notez le rapport grégoire de 1794
c'était un rapport sur
l'universalisation de la langue
française
et bien si vous notez ce rapport dans
votre stock de connaissances vous pouvez
anticiper qu'il vous servira à apporter
du crédit à l'idée selon laquelle la
france n'était pas uni à l'époque de la
révolution ou bien à l'idée selon
laquelle la france actuelle est en
partie le produit de l'état français
voilà pour les exemples souvenez vous
que lorsque vous choisissez une
référence vous devez anticiper les
arguments de dissertation qu elle vous
servira à crédibiliser
enfin la troisième et dernière chose que
vous devez faire pour formater les
connaissances que vous stockez c'est de
préparer l'explication que vous devrez
fournir pour développer chaque
connaissances vous souvenez que lorsque
vous introduisez une connaissance en
dissertation
vous devez ensuite l'expliqué en
quelques phrases alors bien sûr il faut
être capable de le faire
donc vous ne devez pas à prendre les
connaissances dont vous servirez en mode
name-dropping mais vous ne devez pas non
plus lire un bouquin en entier pour
maîtriser la connaissance ce n'est pas
du tout rentable
vous devez simplement être capable de
parler de la connaissance que vous
mobiliser en quelques phrases donc
lorsque vous prenez des notes en
pratique quelques boulettes prinz
suffisent voilà en résumé pour formater
les connaissances en vue de la
dissertation clarifier les anticiper les
arguments qu'elles serviront à
crédibiliser et ne perdez pas trop de
temps sur chaque référence limitez votre
capacité d'explication vous connaissez
maintenant les deux principes cruciaux
pour préparer un stock de connaissances
quantifier le savoir nécessaire et
formaté se savoir
après vous et bien sûr trouver les
connaissances
mais ça ce n'est pas difficile vous avez
des cours et des manuels donc vous
n'avez pas besoin de mes conseils
et enfin vous devrez stocker les
connaissances je pense que vous savez
écrire sur un ordinateur donc pour ça
aussi vous n'avez pas besoin de mes
conseils
allez je passe à la deuxième clé pour
cartonner en dissertation au concours
on ne peut se passer d'une méthode des
cartes
la deuxième que de la réussite en
dissertation course et la méthodologie
la dissertation était un exercice
complexe
donc si vous y allez à larache ça va
être la catastrophe celle inverse que
vous devez faire
vous ne devez rien laisser au hasard
vous devez précisément savoir ce que
vous devez faire tout au long de
l'épreuve
vous suivez un mode opératoire des
consignes vous appliquer des techniques
que vous maîtrisez alors je ne vais pas
vous dire tout ce qu'il faut faire dans
cette vidéo parce que j'en aurai pour
des heures non j'ai une solution plus
simple pour vous inscrivez vous à mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie le lien
de sa fiche est maintenant en haut à
droite et vous pouvez aussi le trouver
dans la description de la vidéo c'est un
cours par e-mail donc vous pouvez
d'abord regarder cette vidéo et puis
vous lirez montcourt après ou dans les
prochains jours voilà donc c'est bon
pour les deux premières clés je vous ai
parlé de la préparation de votre stock
de connaissances et en vous inscrivant à
moncaut par email vous aurez une
méthodologie solide mais à ce n'est pas
encore suffisant pour cartonner en
dissertation au concours
plus je m'entraîne et plus j'ai de la
chance
arnold palmer la troisième clé pour
cartonner en dissertation ou concours
c'est de s'entraîner alors j'imagine
votre réaction
oh mais c'est évident on le savait déjà
oui peut-être que vous le savez mais est
ce que vous le faites maintenant j'en
suis certain si vous regardez cette
vidéo c'est que vous vous entraînez mal
alors comment s'entraîner pour cartonner
au concours il y a trois dimensions dans
importante première dimension vous devez
vous entraîner en conditions réelles
si vous voulez devenir bombe au 100 m
vous n'allez pas vous contenter de faire
des footings
vous n'allez pas passer tout votre temps
à la salle de musculation
non vous allez faire des 100 m et encore
des 100 m le principe qu'il y a derrière
c'est que dans l'entraînement il faut
stimuler le plus possible l'exercice à
réussir donc ne vous contentez pas
d'apprendre votre cour fait un maximum
de plans détaillés rédiger un maximum de
dissertation simuler le plus possible
toutes les opérations que vous aurez à
exécuter le jour j au concours
la deuxième dimension d'un bon
entraînement c'est la régularité
il ya des élèves qui me disent romain
j'ai lu ton cours de métaux dos et j'ai
appliqué tes conseils mais ça n'a pas
marché
alors moi je leur demande tu as fait
combien de plans détaillés dissertation
pendant l'année tu peux me montrer et
ils me répondent toujours la même chose
je n'avais pas le temps je devais
apprendre le court vous aurez beau avoir
à l'entraîneur de rafael nadal si vous
ne tapez pas dans la balle
tous les jours vous ne progresserez pas
et vous perdrez les matches c'est pareil
en dissertation vous avez besoin d'un
volume
minimum d'entraînement alors vous n'avez
pas besoin de travailler autant qu'un
nadal au tennis mais vous devez vous
entraîner régulièrement par exemple vous
pouvez faire un plan détaillé par
semaine c'est l'histoire d'une heure
d'une heure et demie et à la fin de
l'année vous en aurez traiter des sujets
soyez donc régulier ne travaillez pas
par à coups ça ne marche pas si vous
travaillez parakou votre compétence
intellectuelle se dégradera dans les
périodes où vous ne vous entraînez pas
si bien que lorsque vous vous remettrez
à travailler vous repartirez à 0 en fait
la compétence intellectuelle
c'est comme en musculation sans
entraînement le muscle fond et vous avez
besoin de temps pour progresser je le
répète donc entraîner vous régulièrement
travaillé un peu de temps en temps
troisième dimension pour bien vous
entraîner le feedback lorsqu'un coureur
fait un 100 m il a un chronomètre qui
lui permettent d'évaluer sa performance
vous c'est pareil vous devez faire
évaluer votre travail pour savoir ce que
vous avez raté
est ce que vous avez réussi comment
faire et bien vous pouvez déjà demandé à
vos amis il tire peut-être pas très fort
en dissertation
mais c'est toujours mieux que rien vous
pouvez aussi demander à vos profs en
général et ils sont d'accord mais si
vous voulez vous entraînez sérieusement
vous faire corriger systématiquement et
dans le détail
et bien vous pouvez vous inscrire à ma
formation avancée à la méthodologie de
la dissertation parce que je corrige
tout ce que m'envoient mes élèves sans
aucune limite
au contraire moi je les encourage en
envoyer plus de plans détaillés plus de
dissertation parce que je sais que s'ils
le font alors ils cartonneront au
concours
en résumé il y a trois clés pour
cartonner en dissertation au concours
préparé un stock de connaissances
optimisé en volume et en format pour
votre épreuve de dissertation ensuite
maîtrisé une méthodologie solide et
enfin s'entraîner le plus sérieusement
possible
je vous garantis que si vous vous
concentrez sur ces trois clés vous
allait cartonner au concours vous avez
des questions ou des remarques
écrivez moi dans les commentaires
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
qu'elle vous sera utile je suis romain
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle
aristote et vous étiez sur mille idées
de culture générale rappelez vous que
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour cartonner en dissertation
au concours
ep
[Musique]
à